hi everyone this is Jerry this is a live
blitz game okay this is a game against a
2191 player let's go with the Sicilian
defense so this is a four-minute game I
wanted a 5 minute he wanted a 3 so II
just negotiated this is a this is an
opening that I I covered with the Judit
Polgar and Alexandra Castillo
this is already a little bit different
c4 so white is just looking to clamp
down on this d5 square and I believe I
have enough supporters for that right
now so just simple development a5 might
be a move rook b8 Castle I'm not quite
sure what to do with my bishop just yet
I would I would definitely be in favor
of exchanging off light square bishop so
pressure against this diagonal is h6
worthwhile I believe so cuz this could
potentially be a target and I don't
really see this Knight really getting
over in this section of the board so
maybe if I take like this he's gonna
have to give up his bishop if I take
like this my queen is hitting this
bishop since it's unprotected this
bishop blocks the Queen's view of the
bishop so I think I could take here I
don't know if that would be worthwhile
though takes let's try this Bishop takes
I'm just gonna go for this imbalance
Bishop takes Knight takes and then get
my bishop on this diagonal here quickly
hopefully so Castile Queen here might be
a move and sure enough it comes let's
just defend like this so I'm kind of
banking on getting my Bishop on b7 here
and unfortunately I have to move my
Queen in a spot where she's watching
over this square
and so I could I can't so I could get my
Bishop here then again my seventh rank
is very vulnerable so rook c7 might be a
move actually rook c7 would then
threaten f5 with the fork let's try this
so f5 is that's right here how is white
gonna cope with that does white even
cope with it at all I think I could just
play here
f5 does this work f5 and my winning a
piece or am I missing something
let's give this a shot I don't I don't
see what the trick is I think that was
just a blunder f5 wins a piece here pawn
takes I have enough coverage here so
that these rooks really can't do any
harm to me
I think that was just a blunder I'm
supporting everything here you know this
is coming under fire so I think just
Bishop back this is this pawn is gonna
fall soon or maybe oh yeah I was just
getting ready to push here and I would
lose my queen so let's not do that
Bishop back to f8 I believe is the move
to go with and I might end up just
wanting to eventually do this move once
my queen is protected actually there
might be some could I take his rook
somehow let's see
Bishop here
let's go up Bishop b7 just get this rook
involved here my queen is kind of
unfortunately out of play so now I could
do this move I think I just want to do
this move just so I could get my queen
oh so black or white resigned there so
let me just take a quick look at this
game I something was way off very early
on so night here pawn push wouldn't be
good because of just Queen a5 with check
I would get the pawn I think I was so I
miss played at somehow I mean he felt
suspect to a for later on but this might
have been an inaccuracy actually this
right here you know just probably just
Bishop III when you went Bishop Bishop
d2 had the intention of eventually
coming here but kind of just you know
leaves this Bishop unprotected for just
a moment so you know I was able to take
advantage of the unprotected nature of
that and that's often the case in chess
you just need a just one moment where
one of your pieces is unprotected and
you could fall suspect to a variation
that you might not have anticipated but
I think that white still had a good play
here I don't think I think this was too
slow I was trying to pretty much show
that my LightSquared Bishop was gonna be
better than the knight but as it turns
out this Knight was a monster this
Bishop was incredibly good and actually
you know what during the course of this
game I didn't even realize that there
was the potential for a Queen trade here
in fact I probably would have gone for
that if I had seen that but I just
didn't even see that I'm just seeing it
right now so castling was bad because of
just Queen here I think there's just too
much pressure against this point and if
he wasn't if he was a little bit more
aware of that f5 advance after my rook
played to f7 this was now a threat and
that was just overlooked but that's all
for this video I hope you got something
out of it take care bye